it's the monsoon season in Thailand they
expect a lot of water but they haven't
seen this much in 50 years a third of
the country has been inundated at some
point since the summer but Bangkok had
remained unscathed until now 20 minutes
from the city's commercial district this
market sells Buddhist Goodluck charms
but their luck seems to have run out the
market has been flooded for a week and
right beside it flows the mighty chao
praya river there are official warnings
that the waters could climb higher this
weekend but the traders have decided to
stay my [ __ ] I have to keep my
business going I don't know what else to
do but inside it's all flooded there's a
lot of damage Bangkok is the beating
heart of Thailand's economy if the city
center goes underwater it'll cost the
country dearly already some tourists
have decided it's not worth the risk yes
I'm worried but real I'm day tomorrow so
scare amor it's terrible i love that
place the government says it's confident
that bangkok will escape the worst of
the flooding but much of the city is
only two metres above sea level and
there could be more heavy rain on the
way Holly Williams Sky News Beijing